as they're going as he's going to gather
he's getting it locked up in there oh my
god how do i
how about the guard my only here's my
hair i'm getting clipped on the screen
and i'm still pursuing no it was
one-on-one match-up it was a one-on-one
matchup
there was no screener but the thing is
though my only thing with the cat your
hands were here
you gotta just get up here if you follow
me can you follow me or not
i follow you but this is so hard to do
that when he just going to grab me
it's clever yeah and it looks like a
foul but
if i got my hands on it if i'm running
alongside him he's got nowhere to go he
grabbed my arm
i understand get ready
yeah well that is a
calm civil discussion explaining to
kevin durant why he was called for
foul the lead official ed molloy in his
19th
nba season powell gets it up foul before
the
follow-up shot ed molloy a former player
at thomas jefferson university was ecac
player of the year in the early
90s there's the play that durant has
called for his
third foul and he wants the explanation
that was uh very nicely explained to him
i thought
that was that was such a cool exchange
and as a player that's all you want you
want someone to recognize the position
you're in and to explain it to you
what you hate are referees that are just
arrogant and won't
explain it to you and not that there are
many like that but this is what he was
talking about the clip
the play and is like no that's not what
we're talking about we talking about the
one-on-one i know it's tough and that's
all you want i
just i hope the fans enjoyed that as
much as i did just to see what goes on
the back and forth that
everybody has pressure in these games
and the more you communicate
the better it is for everyone